another week another day in Westeros
indeed all right so this is a video on
House of the Dragon episode seven Gonna
Give You spoiler warning right now if
you haven't seen the episode probably
shouldn't watch this video unless you
want to stick around and watch me
prattle on about it in which case you
are welcome to do that but ye be warned
there's a lot that happens in this
episode there's a lot that happens in
every episode of House of the Dragon so
I'm not going to cover all of it just
gonna go by the things that stood out to
me and starting out okay when people
hook up does the internet still do the
thing where you take two halves of the
names and you put it together to make
one name like Ben Affleck and Jennifer
Lopez were benefit because I have so
many Everybody Loves Raymond jokes so
this episode actually started out with
Elena's funeral which I thought was
great for a couple reasons one I don't
feel the show gave me enough time to get
attached to the character Elena so a
funeral is a really good way to do that
you can make the argument it's too
little too late at that point but seeing
everyone Lament The Loss just really
makes you feel like she was a part of
their life she was a part of the world
like the world's just shittier without
her somehow the world of Westeros got
worse than it was also that is the case
in point the fact that there was was a
funeral in Westeros in which everyone
was really sad you don't get a lot of
funerals in Westeros not ones where
people are like oh man what has the
world come to more than a few occasions
of yeah that dude got his ass beat to
death all right what's next even though
man that funeral must have been awkward
if you're looking around you're like
they hate them they hate them they hate
them they want to kill them Eamon steals
the dragon dragon's name I can't think
of right now hey I know look it up how
hard is that that's why I give everyone
and everything nicknames so I can just
remember them in my way I call them bad
[ __ ] because he's the biggest
and the baddest right anyhow Eamon gets
on this Dragon just starts riding the
dragon I was like
wait a minute what I know like dragons
are really monogamous right that's like
his dragon now imagine that Robin got to
be like the batmobile's mine now that's
just the way it goes do not judge me in
my channel for having a Batman Forever
reference in a video talking about House
of the dragon that is how I roll this
episode has some great lines too and the
sea snake was like history does not
remember blood it remembers names dude
that's an incredible line just the
concept of if they're not my lineage but
they have my name I will live on that
does supersede if they're my lineage but
they don't have my name
and then I won't I don't know why that
hit me I was like that's it's more
profound than I should but really the
standout the showstopper moment was that
super kid brawl Death Match I knew blows
were coming it was four on one at a
point but I didn't know it was gonna be
a full-on Hell in the Cell match hell in
the cave anyway and everyone who was at
the funeral scowling at each other
hating each other they were all in that
one room but like what happened it was
basically he said he said little kids
pointing fingers with the indisputable
fact that dude stole their family Dragon
he took my dragon he took my eye it was
the whole thing that's been so awkward
for the parents I love how Damon threw
this whole thing just like leaning up
against the door just smirking like yeah
then it all goes down he's like I guess
I'll get involved now I cracked up
because King's Landing that is some
Jerry Springer Maury Povich [ __ ] right
there you got kids who are not kids of
the father and all the adults are
pointing fingers they'll start coming at
each other with knives
[Applause]
[Music]
that was ice cold when the queen was
like it's fine it's it's fine it can be
paid back I'll just take one of your
kids eyes but what I loved about this is
I didn't know if a kid was gonna die in
the scuffle I was like is a kid gonna
get stabbed is a kid gonna get his head
crushed this is Westeros man it wouldn't
even be the darkest [ __ ] I've seen I
don't think I've been a fan of Westeros
for a while
I've seen some [ __ ] but I didn't know if
someone was gonna die or how they were
gonna get injured it was going to be
permanent I like that feeling but after
all that Runner gets slashed the kids
might get his eyeball cut out then
Eamonn speaks up and he's like it's okay
I lost an eye I gained a dragon he's
right just like Otto Hightower says he
was like that was a fair trade all right
still couldn't help but be like could
you have spoken up sooner not since the
butler spoke to Harry Osborne in
Spider-Man 3 have I seen someone speak
up in a fashion that can only be
described as unfashionably late would
have saved a lot of headache and some
stitches if you just said that earlier
Lenore gets away I was glad because
Lenore gives his whole like hey I
haven't been a good husband I thought I
could have my happiness yours I don't
think it can but I'm committing myself
to you and this family because everyone
knows everyone knows your father knows
your father acts like he doesn't know
but he's just trying to keep the realm
together no he knows he's got a unify
storms coming and then it looks like she
has him killed but then it shows him get
away and I was like
okay it looks like looks like they just
worked that out where this dude just got
away this dude's like
[ __ ] that place
[ __ ] it glad King viserys is still alive
I saw that in the comment section in my
last video someone was like the most
shocking thing is that he's still around
every time the opening credits come on
and I see his name I feel like Palpatine
yeah he is
he's still alive every time every
episode but yeah not only did renera and
Damon hook up now they're married which
means every time the queen here's renera
talk she's just gonna think to herself
it will just happen because that song
transcends space and time I do wish
Dragon lore was more front and center I
wish it was more of a part of this show
season two I hope they bring it to the
Forefront more like Lenore has a dragon
right what happens to his Dragon does
his dad get his Dragon what does his dad
think about the little kid
um amund taking the dragon that's in his
family these are good and fair questions
that I wish the show would concentrate
on because dragons are a huge part of
the culture of the families in the show
and this is actually the real gripe of
this episode the episode was really dark
just in terms of lighting it looks like
they filmed it in the daytime and
artificially darkened the scenes that
were supposed to be at night there are
pictures that I found that looks like
the nighttime scene in this episode but
it's just in the daytime so I think that
that's what they did either way it looks
like muddy [ __ ] all the nighttime scenes
were almost unwashable it was unbearable
I couldn't stand it other than that the
episode was killer it was a great
episode of tensions conflict and people
being like okay everyone knows that your
kids are not his kids there's gonna be a
move made against you she was like all
right Damon
you want to just make the power couple
of the century and I'm glad that they're
bringing the kids to the Forefront
because this family conflict is going to
go on for a while alright so House of
the Dragon episode 7 have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]